we're testing times for Bahrain Navy
tension between the u.s. and Iran means
patrols like this one are increasingly
important
the sailors speak the language of the
sea their aim to reassure tankers it's
safe in the Gulf
despite attacks last year blamed on Iran
this warships part of an international
coalition set up to deter Tehran from
striking again the captain told me about
the mission run out of a US naval base
in Bahrain when we are in our patrolling
area we have the trust to other mission
ships when they are passing through our
duty area when they see us they feel
safe do you imagine that this maritime
security construct is going to be needed
for you know for a good few months
possibly even years I think yes because
being part of this mission is not that
much important for the naval forces as
it is very important for the shipping
companies
perhaps so but it must also be a comfort
for his warship to be linked up with
bigger allies like Britain and the
United States also part of the coalition
together they seek to navigate away
through this highly unpredictable crisis
down there a reminder that this does
have some serious firepower
yeah I mean no we're we're a small
missile Corvette however we have we pack
a powerful punch
we have surface-to-surface missiles as
well we have helicopter capabilities the
crew of the Alma Hawk is ready to fight
if needed but their mission is defensive
to deter attacks on commercial shipping
much of the world's oil and gas passes
through this region so a crisis here had
global consequences
we're in waters off Bahrain Iran's
coastline lies about a hundred miles
from here it's calm now
but this area was incredibly tense last
month after the u.s. killed a top
Iranian General in Iraq an anticipated
Iranian response could have included
attacks against US military targets in
Bahrain or against international tankers
in these waters it didn't but everyone
still on alert there's a hope that by
advertising their presence it will help
to deter trouble it's a gamble but this
tiny Gulf state has little other choice
Deborah Haines Sky News Bahrain